desde acá desde el pentágono se honraron
las 184 víctimas del vuelo 77 de
american airlines que se estrelló en el
lado sudoeste del pentágono desde acá
también marqué mi ley y el comandante en
jefe de las fuerzas armadas de eeuu
reiteró la importancia del servicio
prestado por los estadounidenses que
participaron en las guerras después del
11 de septiembre e insistió mi ley que
la lucha por los valores y contra
enemigos como el talibán no fue en vano
esto a pesar de que eeuu sigue en
diálogos con el talibán en este momento
el ex presidente george de bollywood
sedes pensilvania también habló y dijo
que él lidera un país unido después de
los atentados terroristas una unión que
dice buzz ahora aparece de instante
tanto en nuestra política se ha
convertido en un llamado a la rabia el
miedo y el resentimiento y eso nos deja
con la preocupación sobre nuestra nación
y nuestro futuro dijo balls agregando
que no ofrecía explicaciones o
soluciones también desde shanksville
pensilvania la vicepresidenta kamala
harris insistió que estos ataques de
muestra como el miedo puede ser usado
para crear divisiones en eeuu por su
parte el ex presidente de donoso fue el
único de los ex mandatarios vivos que no
estuvo presente ninguno de los actos de
homenaje a las víctimas del 11 de
septiembre de trump se limitó a emitir
un comunicado en el que criticó la
estrategia de joe vaivén en afganistán
en vez de recordar a las víctimas y
saludar entre otras cosas el papel de
policías bomberos y rescatistas
el presidente joe biden finalizará los
actos protocolarios hoy 11 de septiembre
después de 20 años de los atentados acá
desde el pentágono antes de salir para
delaware donde terminara su fin de
semana